whether it's alien
moon
or the expanse
where would science fiction be without
space mining
but real world space mining companies
backed by big names and millions of
dollars
ultimately haven't materialized
enter luxembourg
one of the smallest countries in the
world
today it's helping companies launch
sustainable space mining endeavors on
the moon and beyond at some point in the
future we will become multi-planetary as
elon musk likes to say
so why not help to accelerate that right
and with a decades-long track record of
making space a profitable business
luxembourg is betting big on everything
from space resources satellites and
training the next generation of space
entrepreneurs
the footprint that luxembourg has in
space is so much bigger than the
footprint that luxembourg has on earth
and i think that's hugely exciting
luxembourg now has the largest space
budget per capita in the world
we tripled the number of space companies
in luxembourg in in less than six years
we have more than 70 companies here in
the space sector
this small country's big ambitions could
open the door to an entirely new world
of possibilities scientific discoveries
and exploration that will allow humanity
to take that next giant leap
how can we have access to the sorts of
potential that the solar system brings
these are real companies that exist in
luxembourg that are trying to you know
innovate in space in order to make life
on earth better but also to make life
beyond earth possible
[Music]
luxembourg given its small size and
strong financial sector
has one of the highest gdp per capitas
in the world
but the industries in which it's
historically depended on steel and then
more recently financial services are
prone to fluctuations
in 1985 after the steel crisis during
the 1970s and 80s the government keen to
diversify its economy helped launch
europe's first private satellite
operator ses
so ses stands for society
european de satellite and we started
life really right back at the very dawn
of delivering television over satellite
increasing the number of channels that
everyone has access to from just a
handful to many hundreds watching sky
more channels more choice
television's new generation
now we operate more than 50 satellites
in geostationary orbit we also operate
20 satellites much closer to the earth
in medium earth orbit so more than a
billion people rely on ses for their
video programming every single day and
so over that 35 year period we've
managed to grow from one satellite in
one slot serving predominantly germany
then europe now we've expanded across
europe but also to india to brazil to
the philippines 360 million households
that look to ses satellites every single
day
ses was a bold innovative move by the
luxembourg government that turned out to
be the right one
it's now the largest satellite company
in terms of revenue in the world
satellite and space is big and hard and
it takes long-term vision and long-term
commitment and that really needs to be
underpinned by a great environment a
great ecosystem but also
real conviction from the government
the space and satellite sector now
represents nearly two percent of
luxembourg's total gdp
and its thriving space ecosystem
highlights the benefit of being a small
country
decisions to enter new industries and
create legal frameworks for new
companies all happen quicker here
[Music]
we are able to take decisions faster
maybe than larger countries you can
coordinate more easily because
everything is smaller you can reach the
other people more quickly and so we are
able to react maybe in a more flexible
and faster way
i think in the case of space it's having
a very you know open and flexible
regulatory regime it's being very
encouraging of startups it's sort of
giving support to companies with a
longer term vision because it's tough to
do that as a startup you generally want
to start developing revenue and business
very very quickly and i think what you
need is that support from a country
that's able to to have that long-term
vision and i think that's something that
luxembourg has done very very well here
given its continued success with ses
which has expanded in recent years to
include rapidly growing data markets
such as telecommunications
mobile network operators and cloud
services
luxembourg wants to go even further
taking big steps to place itself at the
center of the map for space businesses
and so in 2005 we joined the european
space agency and we created a dedicated
team at the government at the ministry
of research at that time
supporting the development of that space
sector and then of course
the sector grew and became more and more
important with more and more companies
and in 2016 we launched the space
resource.lu initiative looking at the
utilization of space resources and there
we saw that we need to actually look
at the ecosystem and the space sector in
a much wider way not only focusing on
giving r d or co-funding to companies
but really looking at
all kinds of different aspects the
international dimension the legal and
regulatory domain the financial side but
also research and education and so we
decided to create the luxembourg space
agency to in the end address all this in
all its complexity with a dedicated
agency
[Music]
among the agency's first initiatives
train the next generation of space
enthusiasts
so the luxembourg space agency was
an initiator to our master's program and
they helped
with resources and funding so we could
launch the program two years ago and
they have been instrumental in the
design of the program and our goal is
very much to tailor it to the needs of
of the sector so our students they do
internships
in some of these companies they do
industrial master thesis projects where
they will be based at a company doing
their thesis project so this helps us to
tailor the program so it meets the
demand that's out there
at the university of luxembourg
students from around the globe learn
different skills related to the space
industry that are in line with
luxembourg's commercial oriented space
program
so right now we're sitting in the luna
lab students here work primarily with
rovers and and learn how to navigate
with them and how to control them we
have the zero g lab where we have forced
air platforms that float on a cushion of
air and can move in two dimensions
frictionlessly
we have the cubesat lab where we can
assemble and test
cubesats
finally our communication is a
networking lab so you can simulate the
orbits of satellite in different
constellations
all of these skills are training the
next generation to not only work in
existing space industries like
satellites and communication
but for the future space ecosystem on
the moon
i do think we will see
moon bases in the not too distant future
and this is a first step i think what
we'll see is that we'll create an
ecosystem where services are provided by
different parties and i believe there
will be an economy in space to sustain
this
another major step for luxembourg was
laying down a legal framework that would
eliminate any uncertainties for space
companies
in 2017
they became the second place to make
harvesting resources in space legal
after the usa
and it's very obvious that in the long
term you will need an international
framework on this but in the meantime if
you want to
progress if you want to
also support this new industry in this
new sector you need to start clarifying
the things and that's why we recognize
the need to indeed implement a first law
on a national level at least starting to
clarify the things on a locksmith level
luxembourg's policies and investment
have attracted the likes of ispace a
private lunar robotic exploration
company first launched in japan
this
vision of expanding the
economy in space by leveraging space
resources was very aligned with the
vision of ispace
and therefore we decided to open an
office here
we want to enable new entrepreneurs new
businesses to to develop their
businesses on the moon because they'll
have a cheap and frequent access to
doing a surface
to achieve this they're building
commercial lunar landers with high
frequency and low cost delivery systems
to the moon
and lunar rovers that can carry cargo
take measurements and collect data to
inform customers of the environment
and what we're seeing you know looking
forward to the lunar ecosystem is that
any business on earth has activity to do
on the moon construction energy
resource exploration resource
utilization all those businesses that
are currently active on earth translate
very easily to the lunar environment we
just need to provide a cheap way to get
there
on the the first mission they will
launch next year our main customer is is
from dubai actually it's the mohammed
bin hashid space center they are
launching their first winner rover on
our spacecraft we also have customers
from canada
from japan so it's a very international
mission
ispace was also awarded two contracts
from nasa to collect lunar regolith and
transfer ownership of the resource to
the agency as part of the artemis
program to the moon
and if we're successful this will make
isps through up so the entity located in
luxembourg the first company to actually
put in practice
the law of space resources that was
passed in 2017.
but getting to the moon and delivering
resources is only part of what an
economy on the moon will need
quickly you realize okay you want to see
a lunar colony develop okay you cannot
bring everything from earth so if you
want to do local manufacturing you want
to be able to produce it locally on the
moon and and then the critical part that
you really need is energy
[Music]
to do this a luxembourg-based company
called monoelectric hopes to turn sand
on earth and regolith on the moon and
mars into solar panels
after winning an award mana electric was
supported by the luxembourg space agency
in securing an r d contract from the
european space agency
this secured initial funding for the
company and allowed it to develop its
technologies
yeah our objective is to be the utility
company of the solar system providing
energy
wherever people may go so we provide
solar panels here on earth for power
resources we want to provide it on the
moon
in space and even when humans go to mars
and beyond we want to be there providing
power the same way that you pay your
utility bill today how great would it be
if you can just plug in
their first product which they hope to
commercialize in the next couple of
years
the terabox
so the short-term focus at mana is our
terrestrial product which is the terra
box which is basically a containerized
solution so it's about six shipping
containers
that we can feed desert sand into the
container and we can produce fully
functional solar panels from that desert
sand
their terrestrial products allow for
monoelectric to create a sustainable
business in the short term while
developing the technology needed for
space which is perfectly in line with
the luxembourg space agency's goals
i think what we've
been able to do at mana is find this
sweet spot where we can
apply technologies both for earth and
for space these two birds one stone
approach it's no longer a horizon of 10
15 years when you might get your return
you're looking at really starting to
generate revenues
shorter term
mana electric also follows closely with
the luxembourg space agency's emphasis
on utilizing space resources for the
future space economy
yeah so in situ resource utilization or
we call it isru it basically stands for
utilizing what's available locally when
you go to the moon
for example isru is applied like okay
let's use the local resources that we
have on the moon to produce goods
to help develop the isru concept and
shepherd in the next generation of
companies the luxembourg space agency
even opened up a facility that's the
first of its kind
it's called esric
or european space resources innovation
center and is dedicated entirely to the
research of space resources
from prospecting of resources to mining
the resources to processing them
for different applications if you're
able to use the resources in space you
don't need to launch everything from the
ground and for example you can think
about just refueling satellites in space
by using fuel generated in space or
servicing satellites which with
different equipment
which is produced in space
whether it's satellite communications or
utilizing space resources
luxembourg is showing that the new space
economy can benefit everyone and is no
longer an exclusive club for only a few
i think the really exciting thing we see
about the innovation in luxembourg right
now around space is it's all about how
to solve problems it's it's how do we
use space to provide
better visibility of what's going on on
earth it's how do we use space to
improve agriculture it's how do we
innovate in space with smaller
satellites with more payloads that can
have an impact on our lives make life
more sustainable i think one of the
things that we're all faced with is
climate change and and how do we protect
the earth for future generations and
space has a huge role to play there it
was the case that only governments could
impact a billion people now individuals
can do that just by innovating and
investing and having a great idea and
having that idea come to market and i
think luxembourg is the perfect
environment for that
[Music]
you